(thump)
- (sighs) Fuck!
I hate wasting time.
What's up, Snapchat?
So, I'm here to, uh---
(whooshing sound)
(gentle R&B music)
♫ Oh yeah ♫
- I'm lucky.
Yeah, I'm lucky.
If the Jets lost the game again,
I think I'd go down to 73 pounds.
I wouldn't eat for a year.
Nobody eats bananas like me!
Nobody!
Gary Vaynerchuk. How are you?
Good, well thank you, I appreciate it.
Hope you had a great weekend.
This has just been the
narrative of my life,
you know, like,
whether it was email marketing
when I had 90 percent open rates in '96,
or Google Adwords when
it was five cents a click,
or starting a YouTube show
within the year of YouTube launching,
or being one of the first
personalities on Twitter,
this is all it is,
it's just,
when is it a year before
everybody else is gonna be there,
or 18 months before everybody
else is gonna be there,
that's when I like to strike.
Not two years, not three years,
I've been writing about Snapchat winning
for three years.
I invested in it well over a year ago,
like, I've believed in
this platform a long time.
The reason I, Gary the brand,
now am getting loud,
is the moment is upon us.
I don't know if they're here.
That would suck.
(doorbell rings)
Hey Rick, it's Gary Vaynerchuk,
how are you?
Super well.
I have in my calendar that
we're recording today,
I'm at the door.
Do you have---
That's in---
Bye-bye.
Your first drama, DRock.
Fuck, man!
And you can keep the
"fuck, man" in the video.
What's up is that I'm
here to record the book,
and I just called the guy,
and he said, nope, it's
Thursday and Friday.
And when I look in my calendar post,
I do see that.
So I'm coming in to the office
to figure out what the fuck is going on.
(gentle R&B music)
Fuck!
I hate wasting time.
What's up, Snapchat?
So I'm here to record my audiobook,
and there's a mixup,
and I fucking hate mixups.
So I will not be recording today.
(sighs)
(gentle R&B music)
♫ You can't love me
♫ The way I need you to love me ♫
- How are you?
- What up?
- Good to see you.
(gentle R&B music)
(sighs)
What's the first thing I need?
- Uh, the shit?
- Just like, true answers.
Yeah, so. So.
- For sure.
- Oh hey, Gary.
I just texted you. (laughs)
I texted you a square
version for Instagram
and long for Twitter,
wasn't sure which one you wanted to use.
- How are we doing with getting
contracts signed for 2016?
- Umm...
(laptop keys clicking)
(sniffing)
- Hey everybody, this is Gary Vaynerchuk,
and this is episode 174
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
I'm a little salty,
I'm supposed to be recording
my audiobook right now,
there was some calendar mixup,
I'm not sure,
haven't gotten to the bottom of it.
What's going on here?
- Troubleshooting.
- What's up?
- Something's acting weird
with the first time computer.
- Is that even, has that even been up?
Is that new?
Got anything good?
- Yeah, I'm just---
- We're doing that Snapchat stuff?
- Yeah, the one that you want.
- Yeah, because it's gonna be double.
We can get two for ones, you know.
Same handle helps, you know.
- Yeah, I think it's cooking.
- Hey, how are you?
- Good, how's it going?
- Real pleasure, how are things?
- Pretty good, how about you?
- Good, man.
- So are we filming the DailyVee?
- We are.
- Oh, okay. (laughs)
- You might make a cameo in Daily Vee.
So, tell me about yourself.
- Hey guys, John Linitz,
I just had my little meeting with Gary,
and he's just so forward thinking,
and he really cares about the employees,
to set up these one on one meetings
and just, like, get a little taste
of what you feel for the company,
and I've just been having a great time.
I really appreciate the time
he sets aside for all of us.
It's awesome.
Thanks man, I really appreciate it.
- Glad you're here.
- Yeah, glad to be here.
- Continued success.
Have a great day.
- Thank you so much.
- Hey, Nina.
- Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, how are things?
- Pretty good.
I'm getting over a cold,
I'm sorry I'm stuffy.
- No worries.
So that was your weekend,
just battling the elements?
(gentle R&B music)
I'm like, super all over my schedule.
What did I miss?
- No, we're fine.
- You did update everything?
- We're fine.
- Okay.
- Um, just FYI,
you're gonna go to the
Knicks game with Wayne
on the second of February,
just that's something
that you asked me for,
and he got back to me.
- Hello.
- Hello, why do you have color?
- I was in Africa for three weeks.
- You tan pretty well.
You were in Vegas for a full week.
- Yeah, but I was indoors the whole time.
- Cool, what's cooking?
- I basically just want to lock down
roles and responsibilities
for platforms department,
and then get confirmation
on what this means.
- Super quick,
we're jumping immediately to A.J.---
- [Gary] Michael has that meeting?
- Uh, you're not on the invite.
- I'm coming.
I just want V.M. social
to be best in class.
Why am I not in this meeting?
- I think it was just a scheduling thing.
We were chatting about it,
Tyler and I were chatting about it.
- I think I'm gonna
jump in there right now.
Is that what's going on?
Okay, bye.
There you go, James.
- How are you?
- Good.
- How'd you do?
- We did well.
♫ Drink will wind you up like a typhoon
♫ Play the room
♫ These type of things we're expecting
♫ Baby please I need a sleeve
♫ I don't like to be unprotected
♫ I've seen these types
of dreams get neglected
♫ I'm getting money now
♫ I told you when the kids were on the bed
♫ And we were sleeping on the little couch
♫ Only had a little clout ♫
- We thought you might want
leadership from the agency
to dovetail with your own.
- No.
Because I just think you'll control it.
Like, maybe, but maybe
after all hands up.
I don't know.
I don't see us putting
stakes in the ground
in our POV's through our social.
- [Rebecca] What about
responding to things
that are happening out in
the world intelligently,
that speaks to the philosophy we have?
- [Gary] Do I really have to link the two?
Like, this is just the first kickoff.
That's why I have to
really think about it.
- [Rebecca] Okay.
- It did get cancelled?
- Yes it did.
- That's good, because that,
I thought that was fucking us up.
- Yes it did, it does.
- See, guys? Things happen for a reason!
- Are you willing to go a half hour late?
- Yes.
They gotta know that my
daughter trumps everything,
and that I wanna be there,
but literally this is the one thing
that I wouldn't move for it.
- [Matt] Okay, cool, then
we are almost perfect.
- [Gary] Okay, I gotta go.
- Hi DRock. Bye DRock.
- [DRock] Hi Nate. Bye Nate.
- Hi, what's up?
I was like, I'm really not camera ready,
I thought this meeting was on Friday!
- Your mom is gonna be super pumped.
- She's gonna be! (laughs)
Get that in there.
- I will.
- She'll love it.
- I love her.
And her daughter.
How are you doing?
- Great, good.
How are you?
- Good.
So I'll make everything right for April,
we have plenty of time.
- Okay, should we chat in March?
- Yeah, I think we should.
- Great.
- Okay.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Thanks, Gary.
- Love you.
- See you soon.
Love you back.
That you can keep.
- Do you wanna straight up chug that?
- [Gary] What, are you trying to make
some Snapchat content?
- Yeah.
But I mean,
I also want you to drink
the water at some point.
- Guys, this is Mike trying to game me
by chugging this water
for his Snapchat purposes.
Mike, do you even care about my health,
or is it just about your Snapchat channel?
- I care about your health.
- (laughs) That was how it ended.
- [Mike] Thank you.
- What about me?
Sarah, what about my snapping?
- Frankly, you're really behind the ball
on getting your story shit
together for Snapchat,
I think.
- Frankly, like, finding a new job
is tough in January. (laughs)
Frankly.
- I'm just a little surprised, that's all.
- What are you talking about?
On the weekends, that's true,
on weekends I'm, like---
- At least you're not just doing, like,
the up your nostrils shot anymore.
- That's true.
Good point, Sarah.
Thanks for the words of encouragement.
- [Mike] I learned all
this snap stuff from you.
- Can you let H.R. know that I want to
personally do your review?
- [Sarah] I would love that actually.
- You got it, sister!
- Also, I think I'm really
good at Snapchat actually.
- All right, fine, DRock.
Throw her Snapchat handle on here.
- [Mike] All right, but
can you chug it? (laughs)
- Yes, Mike, we can chug it.
- [Mike] Let's go!
When no one's watching, guys,
even Gary Vee chugs his water.
- I don't chug my water!
I'm doing this for Mike!
I hate water!
Oh, over there?
- [Mike] All right,
shrimp Caesar salad.
Here you go.
- Get out of here!
Ugh, this guy!
I hate water!
Gabe, you like drinking water?
- I love water!
- Do you want to do more
meetings in New Jersey,
or my question is,
there's a 4:40 flight from
Newark that you could take.
- I'd rather do stuff in Jersey if I can.
What about dentist?
- Yeah, Vayner now he has
courtside tickets to the Knicks.
- Nice!
- A few people asked that,
the way you worded your Instagram,
it looks like I gave you a gift. (laughs)
I saw two or three comments,
and I know this,
Elise goes, did you give him those?
I'm like, no, not exactly.
(gentle R&B music)
- Hey, Dad.
How are you?
I'll see you then, yep.
Okay, okay.
No worries.
- Yo.
- [Voiceover] Hey man.
- Okay.
- [Voiceover] So on the account side,
the account side---
- Hold on one second,
I'm Snapchatting, I want
to make sure I catch you.
- [Voiceover] So on the account side,
the account side,
so the, on the account side---
- You like that better?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, it's great, Gary.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- [Voiceover] The book tour?
- Yep.
I definitely, definitely
am gonna do a book tour
or more in the U.K.
And when I say U.K.,
we could do kind of a
thing where it's like,
a breakfast event in London
and a dinner event or book
signing in Manchester.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, we got it.
- Whatever sells the most god damn books!
- [Voiceover] Yeah, I know.
Do you have a target in mind?
Like, you coming to a city like that---
- One billion books!
- [Voiceover] Okay, realistically.
- Realistically?
I think Alex DiSimone has it,
it's like 4,000 books for
me to travel somewhere,
but obviously if, like,
that means in the U.S.
if I have to go to, like,
you know, to Chicago,
and wasn't planning on it,
because of all the stuff
with our new office there,
we're just maximizing.
I'll take 8,000 because
somebody really wants me,
or I'll take 2,000 in two spots
with just a little train hustle.
Or, or, we'll do one in London
in the morning as a
breakfast business thing,
and I might, I mean it's Europe,
I might hop on a plane and
go to a different country
if someone watches this on Daily Vee
and decides they want me there.
I think Raj has broad enough
shoulders to pull it off,
I just don't wanna bullshit him
and wanna be really up
front with my expectations.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- Cool.
- [Voiceover] That's what I got.
- All right, awesome.
Love you, bro.
- [Voiceover] Thanks, man.
- See you.
How we doing?
See you tonight?
- Oh yeah.
(laughter)
- I'm gonna come out and come in.
Let's both do it.
There's no dressing.
No, just get me what
their ask is on my time
and I'll do it.
It'll be fast.
- [Voiceover] Okay, so, just ask?
- So if you feel like
Snapchat's gonna work for you,
if this is your moment,
sleep less,
hang out less,
watch less football,
and triple attack.
Now!
Triple attack, motherfuckers.
- [phone playback] If
you feel like Snapchat--
- I really feel like this is a
moment for Snapchat, clearly.
For a lot of you debating on like,
is it because of my investment,
or am I hired as a spokesperson,
which I was very flattered by,
I'm pushing because I want
to be historically right,
like I did on the #AskGaryVee Show 174,
where I expand on this,
this is just the moment.
So I'm going all in.
So I'm cashing in all the favors.
I'm helping people,
I'm reaching out to friends
that are big in other areas
trying to get them on,
because I think they're gonna win.
I'm trying to educate my team.
I'm using it as much as possible.
You know, you might post about
it once every seven times
and ask for people to follow you,
because that's how you get more followers,
instead of every four times.
I'm willing to be perceived
as annoying to some,
to squeeze that orange as
much as humanly possible,
because I don't want to have regrets,
because I know that this
is a moment to land grab
on the platform that is going to dominate
the end consumer's attention.
- Good to see you, too.
- Looking good, man!
- Thank you.
You snapping?
- I'm about to.
- What's up, guys?
I am here in VaynerMedia
with the one, the only, Mister Gary Vee.
- Yeah, whatever he recommends.
How you doing, man?
- Good man, how are you?
- Good.
I just wanted to jam a little bit,
I'm sure Jesse and them already told you,
I would like to think
they gave you context
from the meeting we had.
- A.J. says it's imperative
that you're in the meeting.
Do you want to cut recording
short by 30 minutes?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Hey!
- Hi!
- [Gary] How are you?
- Good, how are you?
- [Gary] Really good.
- Good!
Filming!
- Yes, don't worry, all
of it will be edited.
We'll talk about very sensitive stuff.
- (laughs) I was like, all right,
this is quite the conversation to record!
Thank you for the time, I appreciate it.
- Talk to you soon.
How you doing?
- Good, how are you?
- Good, man.
Listen, I really wanna rev
up our communication in '16.
- Me too.
- Good, you're in charge.
- He sent me an email being like,
I wanna talk about this
tweet that got sent.
- [Gary] Okay, record and I'll speak.
- "I change my mind
often," was what you said.
- Okay.
- I didn't know if you
were referring to something
we were talking about before,
or if you have an idea and
you just want to run with it.
- What I didn't do a good job of
in "Jab, Jab, Right Hook,"
is to talk about how free
wheeling the right hook should be.
The right hook is for you.
And so if I have to throw
a shitload of right hooks
for the first month of 2016
because I wanna build up
my distribution channel on Snapchat,
that's what I'm gonna do.
- [India] I think that's
a whole other article.
Like, the thing I didn't talk about enough
in "Jab, Jab, Right Hook."
- That is a great idea.
Let's write an article of like,
oh, by the way---
- [India] The right
hook is freewheeling.
- Maybe we call it round 13.
Since most things, round 13.
- The one thing I didn't...
ooh, clickbait!
- Round 13, colon, like, you know,
one major clarification
from "Jab, Jab, Right Hook."
And let's start it with, like,
with my new book "#AskGaryVee" coming,
and maybe hark back to, yeah.
- [India] I like that.
- Because what I didn't do,
and obviously everybody's
getting a huge preview,
this is why DailyVee
is gonna be monster,
I want this all in here, DRock,
basically me in here the whole time,
is, plus it will be fun for people to see
how articles get done,
they get to see that it is me,
but like, how we structure it.
- Right, yeah.
Um, it's Gary.
We had a meeting with coms,
with Rebecca and Emily,
like, me, Andy, Britney,
and Coms all met together,
to talk about ways in which we could make
getting your content syndicated
much more streamlined
and efficient and get it syndicated more,
and one of the big things
that we really need to do more
is talk to them about, like, headlines,
a lot of the time,
and like how we're positioning an article,
so Andy and I were hoping
to get your approval
on the next eight articles
that we're going to write.
So now I have to go to a meeting
with the rest of the team.
Bye.
- [Gary] Bye, India.
- That was my first real
DailyVee appearance,
I just realized.
Today, yeah.
- [Gary] Awesome! You did it!
Yo, Brooklyn, we did it!
- Gary.
- How are you my man?
- [Voiceover] Good, how are you?
- Super well.
And that's actually
super interesting to me.
Has the show even made like,
because I know like, you're here.
- Yeah, I feel like I get a good sense
because I've been
watching #AskGaryVee too
and I see you around like,
I know that you are what you stand for.
- But you know that your friends
and other people on the
outside are always like,
is it really?
- Exactly.
So this is like a nice
glimpse into your daily life.
- Awesome.
What's cooking, my man?
No, this is always going on now.
- [Voiceover] Oh, okay.
- This is just the way the world is now.
- [Voiceover] Make sure
I look good, DRock.
Hi, how are you?
- Good.
- Um, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- I actually just reached
out to Matt on Saturday,
so I'm like, this is the
fastest turnaround time.
- Yeah, because I had a very weird day.
But I'm happy now.
- Um, so I wanted to get time with you
to ask you for some advice.
- It's good to see you.
- [Voiceover] You too.
- See you.
Don't edit any of that.
I want all her business ideas.
- [Voiceover] No! Edit all of it!
- Hello!
- Hello there!
- [Voiceover] How are you?
- Good, how are you?
- [Voiceover] Good!
- What's cooking?
Our building is attached to the High Line.
- It's amazing.
- Like, literally attached to it.
Like, and we're moving in
right at that time of year,
like the first lunch day,
just like, 400 people
are gonna be outside.
- Cool.
- Great to see you, stay well.
- Bye, DRock.
(gentle R&B music)
♫ Oh yeah ♫
- I really wanna be involved.
- Yes, please.
- Cool.
- [Voiceover] Same page.
- Cool, but use me.
- [Voiceover] Okay, yes please.
- I work for you.
- [Voiceover] Great!
- Congrats.
- Back to work, Gary!
- Yes, ma'am.
(kissing sounds)
Yay!
Hi, Hannah!
- [Voiceover] Hannah,
say hi to Uncle Gary!
- Hi, Hannah!
Hi Hannah!
Look, wow?
- [Voiceover] Scooter, right?
- Is that your scooter?
Aww! You're so cute!
You look so much like your mommy.
- [Voicevoer] Okay, in a minute.
- Okay, let's push it again.
- [Voiceover] Max, look.
- Wow, Max.
That's a big six year old you are now!
- [Voiceover] I think we'll
have to take the nod from Jason.
- See where Jason is, yeah.
- To see if he's gone through, like,
you know, check in with Sue,
before bringing that up to Jeeves.
- See ya.
- Thanks!
- How's it going?
How was your New Year's, all that?
- Good, good.
- I feel like the momentum,
though we haven't had a meeting,
I definitely feel like through
things I've been communicating to Andy
to prep for seven--- sixteen,
and things of that nature,
it seems like there's more
momentum and things to be done
and things of meaning that have been done
more recently,
I feel like we're hitting a
better cadence of momentum
from the way I'm auditing you from afar,
is that, do you see
that to be true as well?
- Yeah, I feel like there's a lot more,
just, there's a ton more stuff,
and I feel like there's
been more delegation,
just in general, like, responsibilities.
- [Gary] That's right.
- It's like, oh, okay,
I own this, this, and this,
now I can run with that.
- That's right. I'm excited.
There will be more clarity around this,
but this is the,
really there's another reason,
just to teach you how I manage,
there's another reason I like this.
You find out how much bandwidth
somebody actually has.
Or I can adjust them.
Hello.
- [Voiceover] Hi!
- How are you?
- [Sam] Good, how are you?
- Good!
So um, let's pick up our conversation.
- [Sam] Thanks!
- Thank you, Sam.
Super, super well, Maggie.
How are you?
- I'm great.
How's CES?
- Great.
- Cool.
- I just want to take
a couple minutes and,
you know, start establishing
a communication funnel.
- [Maggie] Cool.
- I'm super impressed by you.
- [Maggie] Thanks.
- I really like the work you do.
- [Maggie] Thank you.
- And I'd like for us to
know each other better.
I almost went in to that---
I almost went into this
room because I saw you.
And I have my, that's so weird!
- I'm flattered.
- Bye guys!
That's just a bunch of B-list
Snapchatters hanging out!
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] Hello! Welcome back!
- [Gary] Thanks.
- [Voiceover] We're back.
- [Siri] My pleasure, as always.
- Oh, Siri's here.
Great. I think I can make a 7:30 anywhere.
7:30, D.C.? Too far.
Connecticut, Philly, New York, Jersey.
Who wants it?
Anything good from Dallas?
They had a couple things brewing.
- So we have an offer for
three thousand right now.
- [Gary] Get the fuck out of here.
- Yeah, I have, like---
- [Gary] This was my theory
on this whole--- really?
This is what we should do.
We need to run ads.
I went organic.
I didn't even fucking go
organic on my Facebook post,
I didn't even geo it.
- I know.
(laughter)
- [Gary] Do you really?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Fuck.
This is a wrench to the whole thing.
Like I kind of just feel like just being,
just, Chicago, who wants it?
(laughter)
Cleveland, who wants it?
I honestly will sell a
hell of a lot more books
than any of this horse shit!
I don't know, like we'll
put posters up like,
Dallas, we're coming,
we've got this opening,
we don't want to be inefficient,
and now I have 3,000 books sold,
like that's super interesting. Right?
- I still feel really confident,
and there's a couple more emails
that I haven't even looked at yet.
- We're gonna do a call
to action for the South!
Who wants... Andrew?
Who wants the South?
Um, the night of March 9th?
Anyway, let's do a call to action,
just to make the design.
Like, this is clearly working.
I knew it was going to.
Alex, if we don't hit number one
on the New York Times bestseller list,
what are you gonna do?
- Quit.
- Quit what? Life?
- No, no.
(laughter)
- I don't think he got it in.
- [phone playback] What are you gonna do?
Quit.
Quit what, life?
- Yeah, good.
- Save... no.
Save Alex.
(laughter and chatter)
- This is actually a very good thing.
And I'll say it in a way
that will make it funny.
Anything that tastes like a sale,
you see something in the comments,
like you check, I'll use
this as a good example,
you just wanna see the image
that you made for the thing,
and you just see something,
like I'd rather Alex get four
emails from all of you like,
hey, do you see what Lance
said in the comments?
Than not.
Let's all be very vigilant of anything,
including, you read something
in your Twitter stream
of like, somebody bought a
thousand books from somebody,
like anything that makes
your ears perk up on a sale,
I think Britt you're gonna have
a lot of opportunity for it,
let's make sure we focus on that.
All right? Cool.
Thanks, guys.
Yes!
Um, all right.
Thanks, DRock. Good hustle.
Later, David.
What, you thought it was over?
No way.
Dinner meetings. Times two.
Let's go.
Phil and I are talking about
how late my meetings are.
Phil, is it true that this 8:13 meeting
is the earliest we've ever
had a business meeting?
- Absolutely.
Well, it started at 10:45.
- Time for the next meeting.
Meeting on meeting on meeting
on meeting on meeting.
♫ I'm getting money
♫ Yeah ♫
(gentle R&B music)